- Next guest first came into our homes
on the MTV show, "Laguna Beach".
She's also starred in her own
show called, "Very Cavallari".
Now she's a business woman
with her own jewelry line,
Uncommon James, and her new,
"True Comfort" cookbook is out now.
Let's welcome into the studio,
Kristin Cavallari everybody.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers)
- (indistinct) new normal.
- Yes, I know, it's weird.
- Wow, hi guys.
- It's so far.
Everybody is inclined to come here,
'cause that's normal, but yes.
- Of course.
- I love your outfit.
- Thank you.
- It is so great.
- Yes, how are you?
- I'm good, I'm excited to be here.
- Well, thank you for coming,
and meet Jamie Lee.
- Yes, hello, how are you?
- Hello.
- I know we both have kids,
so has it been crazy
over the last few months?
- You know, I'm in Nashville,
and so I'm very thankful,
because there's some normalcy,
I'm out in the country.
And my kids have been in school,
you know, since early August.
And I don't know,
it's just a little bit
different out there,
so I'm really thankful that we're there.
And during the whole pandemic,
I was able to tell my kids to go outside
and ride a bike, you know,
so we've been fine, you know,
and my kids are happy
to be back in school.
My kids are eight, six and four,
so we weren't in a position
where I was necessarily
having to do homeschooling,
you know, I tried a little bit,
but it wasn't like, if I don't do it,
it's gonna be make or break.
So I felt like we were in
a very fortunate position.
- Wow, that is awesome.
Man, 'cause homeschool, that all,
that's been really difficult
for a lot of families.
- Yeah.
- So you also brought some
pieces from your jewelry line.
- Yeah, so these are some pieces
from our fall Uncommon James collection,
and everything was inspired
by my Italian roots.
So last year I actually got to go to Italy
and meet some Cavallari's-
- I love Italy.
- That I didn't
even know existed, it was incredible.
So yeah, kind of a nod
to old world heritage.
And then we actually
just launched Demi-Fine.
So there's a couple of
Demi-Fine pieces of jewelry,
and this is sort of middle of the road.
So it's not fine jewelry,
but it is 14 karat,
gold plated sterling
silver and real diamonds.
And we did Demi-Fine because-
- That's fine where I'm from girl.
- Yes, I know, it's great, yeah.
- When it's real diamonds, it's fine.
- Yeah, you don't have
to say anything else.
But obviously price
point is important to me,
and so it's still accessible.
So there's a few items up there
from the new Demi-Fine collection as well.
- That's exciting, that's so cool.
So you decided to end your
show "Very Cavallari",
you decided to end it after three seasons.
- Yeah.
- Was that a hard decision to do?
- It was, however, it was
definitely the right decision.
And once I made the decision,
I had such a sense of relief.
I was getting a lot of anxiety about it,
my life has changed very much from-
- Mine too.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We only have her story.
It's fine, we have another one
and it's great,
- It's all good, yeah,
we have our own journey,
it's totally cool.
But I just knew, you know,
I have three little kids,
and I've never been someone,
even though I am from
the reality TV world,
I've always sort of kept my life,
somewhat private in a sense,
and kept the camera's at an arm's length.
And I wasn't gonna expose
my divorce on camera,
and have my kids see that one day.
So I decided to walk away from it.
- Yeah, that's a good
mama, that's a mama bear.
So you also just got some new ink as well?
- I did.
- Yeah, I am addicted.
- So I heard that,
I had no idea you,
- I have like 17.
- Had so many tattoos.
- I know because a lot
of them are like small,
they're all over the
place and they're all,
did you ever see that movie,
it was "Memento" or what was that movie,
and he wrote everything on his-
- Yes.
First of all, I love that movie,
two, a little different my
story, but (indistinct).
But I just mean like, I love
that they're all memories,
so I have so many, what are your new ones?
- So this is "CJS" in cursive,
so my kid's first initial,
and then I got a little butterfly,
but I will tell you this
one is fading a little bit,
because it's so thin, my
tattoo artist said that,
with some of these ones,
you might have to 'em a couple of times.
- That's like the one on my finger.
They were like,
"You shouldn't do that."
And I was like,
"Do it!"
- "Just do it!"
And then I have the
Capricorn symbol tattooed
on the back of my neck
and a star on my foot,
because that's what you do when you're 18.
(laughs)
Could've been worse
though, so (indistinct),
it could have been way worse.
I'll take the star.
But my tattoo artist let me tattoo him,
which was wild and crazy.
Never thought in a million
years, that would happen.
So I tattooed the same
butterfly on his arm,
which he, you know, just
sprung on me day of,
I was like,
"Are you sure you want me to tattoo you?"
- Like, I wanna tell you,
this is a poor decision you're making.
- I was like,
"It's not gonna be good, but okay."
But what a cool experience, it was fun.
- I would be terrified.
Jamie Lee, do you have any tattoos?
- I do not, I am
untattooed, except for the-
- You are a clean temple.
- Lines on my face,
which are tattooed from my experience.
But my daughter, my
daughter's name is Annie,
and my nickname for Annie is "Lulu".
And she has "Lulu"
tattooed on her shoulder.
- Which is adorable.
- Which literally made
me start sobbing, that she would put
the nickname that I had
for her on her shoulder.
- Oh my God.
- But no, I have no ink.
I have not been inked.
- I will tell you this, my
mother was so against it,
you know, we're from the
roots of Bible Belt world,
where it's like, your body is a temple,
and I was like,
"It's my temple!"
And so anyway, all of a sudden,
my sister and I both like tattoos,
and so all of a sudden,
my mother's the one who
came up with this idea,
and we ended up getting, she got a tattoo.
- Wow!
- We didn't even
have to convince her, she
wanted to share the moment,
she knew we both loved them,
and like, it's her only
tattoo I'm pretty sure.
But it's like a sun and I'm the moon
and my sister's the star,
and we're both in the center of her sun.
And she loved it too, so see,
it's not so renting
the body, I don't know,
maybe you should get her
a little nickname on you.
- No, no.
- It's never too late.
- No, I don't think so.
(audience laughs)
- She didn't even say a
word, you said an attitude.
No, it's not happening.
I love you so much Jamie.
So Kristin's cook book
is called "True Comfort",
and her Uncommon James
jewelry line is out right now.